wir gehen jetzt zu diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt den die
Bundestagspräsidentin schon aufgerufen
hat Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren
beschleunigen an Brücken und Fernstraßen
hat die Union hier eingebracht erster
Redner ist Florian Müller aus dem
Verkehrsausschuss wir können es uns
ansehen in Lüdenscheid im Sauerland an
der A45
wo die Rahmen der Talbrücke nun seit
einem Jahr gesperrt ist heute seit einem
Jahr leiden die Menschen im Sauerland
heute seit einem Jahr suchen die
Menschen im Sauerland nach einer
Perspektive und lassen Sie uns deshalb
auch heute darüber sprechen was das für
die Menschen vor Ort bedeutet für eine
Familie die vielleicht gerade das Haus
gekauft hat damit die Kinder endlich mal
draußen spielen können das geht jetzt
nicht mehr weil LKW an LKW PKW an PKW
einen Umleitungsstrecken im Dauerstau
stehen Stoßstange an Stoßstange und seit
einem Jahr haben sie nicht mehr richtig
geschlafen aber trotzdem Schlafmangels
müssen Sie morgens noch früher aufstehen
damit sie pünktlich sind damit die
Kinder pünktlich
in dem Kindergarten sind pünktlich
in der Schule und damit sie selber
pünktlich am Arbeitsplatz kommen die
Pflegekraft die einen bei mobilen
Pflegedienst arbeitet sie schafft es
nicht mehr pünktlich zu ihrem Patienten
sie kann es nicht mehr schaffen
pünktlich die Medikamente zu
verabreichen vielleicht schafft sie es
zu dem ein oder anderen Patienten gar
nicht mehr
das macht eine Sperrung mit einer Region
es nimmt jegliche Perspektive und
deshalb ist es richtig dass es jetzt so
weit ist dass auf den Umleitungsstrecken
zumindest Tempo 30 gelten wird es ist
gut dass sie
dass die transitverkehrer aus der Region
verbannt werden aber liebe Kollegen das
hilft nur begrenzt es sind die Symptome
die wir damit bekämpfen wir müssen doch
endlich an die Ursachen heran wir müssen
Familien Unternehmen einzeln der Region
insgesamt helfen die beste Lösung ist
die beste Hilfe ist eine so schnell wie
möglich aufgebaute Brücke das ist
Ursachenbekämpfung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und deshalb ist es richtig deshalb ist
es richtig dass es hier auch in diesem
Hause
fraktionsübergreifend eine Haltung gibt
diese Region braucht Hilfe
aber auf diese Aussage ist doch viel zu
wenig bislang passiert und in der
Hoffnung auf diese Aussage sind die
Menschen inzwischen verunsichert sie
haben zum Teil die Nerven verloren die
Nerven sind strapaziert die Region sie
ist dabei den Glauben an die Berliner
Politik zu verlieren und es gibt doch
die Handlungsmöglichkeiten es gibt die
Hilfsmöglichkeiten wir haben sie
vorgeschlagen wir haben sie Ihnen
vorgeschlagen und was haben wir gehört
zuletzt in der letzten Woche dass ich
das Verkehrsministerium mit dem
Umweltministerium darüber streitet ob
die Beschleunigung von Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren denn auch für
Autobahnbrücken gelten sollen
und das ein Jahr nach der Vollsperrung
was für eine traurige Botschaft für
diese Region
aber deshalb
liegen wollen wir heute nach vorne
schauen wir wollen heute Ihnen einen
Vorschlag machen einen Vorschlag für
einen schnellspurgesetz für
Brückensanierung wir wollen damit die
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren bei
sanierungsbedürftigen Brücken um
zweieinhalb Jahre verkürzen das ist eine
Perspektive für die Region und für viele
andere Regionen in Deutschland
und deshalb ist es doch richtig wenn wir
darauf achten dass wir künftig in
solchen Fällen bei Ersatzleuten
Neubauten keine
Planfeststellungsverfahren mehr brauchen
wir sorgen dafür dass wir das
Vergaberecht in dringenden Fällen extrem
straffen können und lassen Sie uns doch
da wo es besonders dringend ist wo eine
Region so massiv betroffen ist wie das
Sauerland wie Lüdenscheid lassen Sie uns
dafür sorgen dass dann das
Bundesverkehrsministerium eine Ausnahme
bei der Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung
zulassen kann denn am Ende geht es doch
darum am Ende geht es darum dass wir
gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass es eine
leistungsfähige Verkehrsinfrastruktur in
Deutschland gibt denn damit sorgen wir
für eines wir sorgen dafür dass die
Regionen vor Lärm vor Emissionen und von
den Industrialisierung geschützt sind
und wir sorgen dafür dass es wieder
einen ruhigen Schlaf gibt deshalb ist
das auch heute ein Vorschlag an
Zusammenarbeit wir heiligen Ihnen heute
die Hand wir wollen mit Ihnen gemeinsam
den Menschen im Sauerland helfen dafür
sorgen dass es nicht nur im Sauerland
Hilfe gibt sondern auch dafür sorgen
dass es anderen Regionen nicht einen
solchen verkehrssupergau geben wird das
hilft der Region das hilft unserem Land
und das ist doch dann auch heute die
wichtige Botschaft lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam die Bremsklötze lösen lassen
Sie uns gemeinsam mehrere Gänge
hochschalten lassen Sie uns gemeinsam
auf die schnellspur gehen herzlichen
Dank
Florian Müller hat den Antrag der
cdu/csu-fraktion vorgestellt zu
beschleunigten Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren für Brücken und
Fernstraßen und ähm hintergrund ist ein
Vorgang in seiner Heimat im weitesten
Sinne nämlich die marode A45 Brücke bei
Lüdenscheid seit einem Jahr voll
gesperrt und da kann man sich ungefähr
vorstellen was das für die Orte und
Städte in der Umgebung bedeutet wenn der
ganze Verkehr nicht über die Autobahn
gehen kann sondern durch eben diese
Ortschaften fließen muss Jürgen Berghahn
für die SPD-Fraktion Istan
grundsätzlich grundsätzlich hat er
Entwurf einige gute Punkte vorzuweisen
denn selbstverständlich müssen
planungsgenehmigungsverfahren deutlich
schneller ablaufen als es in der
Vergangenheit der Fall war nur dafür
braucht es diesen Antrag tatsächlich
jetzt nicht mehr denn die Koalition hat
den letzten Monaten zahlreiche Maßnahmen
verabschiedet bereits umgesetzt und
arbeiten natürlich an weiteren
Verbesserungen das oster- und
Sommerpaket zeigen bereits Wirkung und
mit dem herbstpaket wird die Regierung
sehr bald ein Gesetzentwurf vorlegen
indem sie dann eigentlich ja auch
zustimmen können erst vor zwei Tagen hat
die Ampelkoalition einen Gesetzentwurf
zur Beschleunigung von
verwaltungsgerichtlichen Verfahren im
Infrastrukturbereich beschlossen dieser
sieht unter anderem eine deutliche
Verschlankung von Gerichtsverfahren vor
die es vor allem bei Großprojekten
Bauprojekten oftmals gibt Verfahren zum
Planungsrecht werden erst und
letztinstanzlich beim
Bundesverwaltungsgericht liegen
dafür zusätzliche Stellen erhält die CDU
CSU fordert eine Kürzung der
planfeststellungsbedürftigkeit das
wollen wir umsetzen in dem zum Beispiel
bei Ersatzneubauten die
Genehmigungsfreiheit ausgeweitet und der
Bau dann direkt nach dem neuesten Stand
der Technik und der tatsächlichen
Verkehrsbelastung gebaut wird hinzu
kommt dass er Ersatzneubauten die
Voraussetzung für geplante bzw
vorhersehbare Erweiterung ebenfalls
direkt mitgeschaffen werden das bedeutet
erstens eine Verkürzung der
Genehmigungsphase zweitens Mittel und
langfristige Verbesserung der
Infrastruktur und drittens die komplette
Einsparung eines weiteren genehmigungs-
die cdu/csu fordert Vergabeverfahren zu
verschlanken und damit zu vereinfachen
auch dies ist längst umgesetzt
beispielsweise durch die funktionale
Ausschreibung Planung und Bau liegen in
einer Hand und werden nicht mehr an
verschiedenen Auftraggeber vergeben das
war auch ein Wunsch aus der Bauindustrie
bei der Ausschreibung ist die
Baugeschwindigkeit in Zukunft ein
wichtiges vergabekriterium auch da
wieder Zeit gewinnen dazu gibt es ein
verfahrensplan der den gesamten Prozess
von Anfang bis Ende aufzeigt und somit
ein konkreter Fahrplan liegt
die sind nur einige Beispiele dafür dass
die Regierung längst an der Arbeit ist
und ganz konkrete Lösungen erarbeitet
während die Opposition noch Anträge oder
Gesetzesentwürfe stellt
liebe Kollegen Kollegen der CDU sie
haben in Ihrem Entwurf übrigens die
Bevölkerung vergessen sie haben zwar
jetzt angesprochen wie es dort aussieht
aber das ist wirklich bemerkenswert da
die Baustellen und Umleitungen von die
Anwohnerinnen und Anwohner eine echte
Belastung darstellen oft auch über
mehrere Jahre da ist es nicht nur
menschlich sich der Sorgen und Probleme
der Leute anzunehmen sondern für die
Beschleunigung vom direkten Projekten
auch unerlässlich durch Transparenz
Mitsprache werden die Betroffenen mit
ins Boot geholt und was erfahrungsgemäß
dann auch zu mehr Akzeptanz und das
Folge dessen zu weniger klagen führt
auch das wieder Zeit gewinnen
aus diesen Gründen hat die Ampel bereits
im März das zukunftspaket
leistungsfähiger Autobahnbrücken
vorgelegt und deutlich gemacht dass eine
frühzeitige Abstimmung mit allen
Beteiligten vor Ort äußerst wichtig ist
und Kollege Müller ich kann Ihnen das
nicht ersparen war der Autobahnbrücke
Ramos bezahlt möchte auch noch erwähnen
mit freundlicher Genehmigung der
Präsidentin dass die rametzter Brücke
gar nicht in so einem katastrophalen
Zustand hätte kommen müssen wenn die CDU
NRW Regierung ihren Job richtig gemacht
hätte im August
ich kann Ihnen das nicht ersparen im
August 2018 hat der damalige NRW
Verkehrsminister Hendrik wüst einen
Bericht herausgegeben der den Zustand
und die Sicherheit vom Brücken bewertet
die rammetetalbrücke hat damals die
Zustandsnote 3 nicht ausreichend
erhalten es wurde festgehalten dass eine
Verstärkung sowie eine satznummer nötig
ist die Brücke aber bis 2025 nutzbar
sein soll dies war eine katastrophale
Fehleinschätzung von Herrn Hendrik wüst
denn die Zustandsnote zeigt auf dass es
dringende Maßnahmen eingeleitet werden
müssen sie gibt aber keinen direkten
Aufschluss über Art und Umfang der
Schäden die logische Konsequenz wäre
wohl gewesen dass man genau dies prüft
und dann nicht nur darauf hofft dass sie
Brücke irgendwann bis 2025 durchhält das
ist allerdings nicht passiert und somit
musste die Brücke 2021 gesperrt werden
alles in allem müssen wir den Entwurf
ablehnen da er durch die vorausschauende
Arbeit der Bundesregierung sicher
erledigt hat vielen Dank
Jürgen Berghahn aus der SPD-Fraktion
spricht hier auch noch mal ein Konflikt
an denen es insbesondere in
Nordrhein-Westfalen gibt zwischen SPD
und CDU Abstimmung es sind noch fünf
Minuten Zeit sollte es jemanden hier im
Raum geben der noch nicht abgestimmt hat
dann ist jetzt noch fünf Minuten lang
die Möglichkeit dazu so
Bundestagspräsidentin
namentliche Abstimmung hin die ihr noch
läuft zum Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht und
ich hatte angefangen zu sagen es gibt
einen ähm veritablen Konflikt zwischen
SPD und CDU in Nordrhein-Westfalen
überleben diese Brücke ob man da nicht
führte früher schon Maßnahmen ergreifen
müssen SPD verweist auf die in damaligen
Verkehrsminister wüst die CDU verweist
darauf dass es sich ja hier um eine
Bundes Angelegenheit handelt daher seine
Brücke sei die zum einer
Bundesfernstraßen gehören jetzt am
poolte die hat Spanien für die
afd-fraktion ist die Situation in
unserem Land eine katastrophalle das
kann man nicht anders sagen das
bestätigen auch alle Aussagen hier wir
haben eine marode nicht mehr
ausreichende Infrastruktur in
Deutschland und wir haben eine Bauzeit
inklusive der Planungen von ungefähr 20
Jahren jeder wir hier jetzt im Parlament
sitzt und über einen Bauvorhaben
diskutiert muss davon ausgehen dass er
nicht mehr im Parlament sitzt wenn es
realisiert wird das ist ein untragbarer
Zustand
warum ist das so das ist nicht so weil
wir eine unfähige Bauindustrie hätten
die baut in vier Jahren im Schnitt das
ist so weil wir 16 Jahre lang klagen und
planen können in diesem Land warum
können wir 16 Jahre lang klagen und
planen weil sie hier Gesetze gemacht
haben die dazu führen dass eine
beliebige Organisation praktisch zu
jedem Zeitpunkt im Planungsverfahren
eingreifen kann und dieses Verfahren
verzögern und da hilft es auch nicht
Herr Berghahn da hilft es auch nichts
wenn Sie die Gerichtsverfahren
beschleunigen wollen das ist alles
Augenwischerei sie sabotieren die
Infrastruktur dieses Landes und das seit
vielen Jahren
und in dem Zusammenhang in dem
Zusammenhang müssen wir immer sagen ihre
Ausrede ist dass das alles so sein muss
wegen europäischer Gesetzgebung sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren in Italien
stürzt eine Autobahnbrücke ein und zwei
Jahre später steht die neue
Autobahnbrücke an dieser Stelle ist
Italien keine Demokratie gehört Italien
nicht zu Europa das ist doch alles
Unsinn was sie erzählen sie wollen das
nicht und der Schlüssel den Schlüssel um
die Probleme in diesem Land zu beheben
den kennen Sie auch ganz genau der liegt
nämlich in der Umwelt
Verträglichkeitsprüfung der sogenannten
UVP und der liegt in der
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung und sie
schaffen es wenn Sie diese UVP per
Ausnahme herausnehmen schaffen sie es
ein lng-terminal in kürzester Zeit in
diesem Land zu bauen und sie wissen auch
dass der Schlüssel genau in dieser
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung liegt weil
sie die nämlich bei den Projekten die
Ihnen wichtig sind nämlich
Schienenprojekte gezielt rausgenommen
haben und für diese Projekte in diesem
Haus hier maßnahmengesetze beschließen
können so dass sie diese Projekte die
Schienenprojekte schnell umgesetzt
kriegen und weil sie diese Ausnahmen
kennen muss sich unterstellen dass wenn
sie das nicht für Straßen anwenden es
reine Sabotage ist Sabotage an den
Menschen in Lüdenscheid ja wohl der
Bergmann so ist es und deshalb begrüßen
wir deshalb begrüßen wir ja auch den
Entwurf der Union wir können uns in
weiten Teilen den Gedanken die dort
formuliert sind anschließen und ich muss
hier mal sagen ich finde es toll dass
sie diesen Schritt machen aber wer hat
noch mal die letzten das müssen sich
jetzt anhören wer hat nochmal die
letzten 12 Jahre im Verkehrsministerium
gesessen ja genau und da sehen sie da
sehen sie da sehen Sie ganz einfach wenn
sie vernünftige Politik für dieses Land
machen wollen dann können Sie das nicht
mit der Sabotage Partei Deutschlands
machen das geht halt nicht ja und es
geht auch nicht es geht auch nicht dass
hier eine FDP in der letzten Legislatur
super fast die gleichen Vorschläge wie
die Union jetzt in Entwürfen hier ins
Parlament bringt und wenn sie im
Verkehrsministerium sitzt in einer
Koalition mit Leuten die dieses Land
eben nicht voranbringen wollen dann ist
diese FDP nicht der Meinung dass die
Vorschläge aus der letzten Legislatur
gut waren lieber Herr Wissing sie haben
ihre Wähler getäuscht sie hätten alle
Möglichkeiten gehabt hier ein Gesetz zu
machen das dementwurf der Union
entspricht und das in dem Entwurf der
AFD aus der letzten Legislatur auch
entspricht wir haben nämlich das gleiche
was sie hier fordern auch schon
gefordert infolgedessen sehen wir hier
eine komplette Verdummung der Wähler in
diesem Land sie wollen keine schnelle
Sanierung von Autobahnbrücken und sie
täuschen die Wähler wenn sie
gegenteiliges behaupten liebe Kollegen
von der Union wenn sie Politik für die
Infrastruktur unseres Landes machen
wollen finden Sie dazu Partner rechts
von ihnen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
bevor ich die nächste Rednerin Aufrufe
komme ich nochmals zurück zur
namentlichen Abstimmung die Zeit ist
abgelaufen ich gehe davon aus dass jetzt
auch alle abgestimmt haben dann schließe
ich die Abstimmung und bitte die
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu beginnen und das
Ergebnis der Abstimmung wird Ihnen zu
einem späteren Zeitpunkt bekannt gegeben
und dieser Zeitraum wird wahrscheinlich
in zehn maximal 15 Minuten sein der Ball
geht es hier weiter um
planungsbeschleunigung was Brücken und
Fernstraßen angeht dann Antrag der
Unionsfraktion und dazu jetzt Susanne
Menge aus der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen sie es ob Frau im
Verkehrsausschuss
meine sehr verehrten unschuldigung
verehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrter
Herr Minister sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ich bin vor zwei Wochen im Aartal
gewesen und Herr Müller die Dramatik die
sie hier gerade vorgetragen haben die
möchte ich kurz auf diesen Ark Gebäude
und wirklich dramatischen Zustand in
Ahrweiler fokussieren wir haben dort die
B266 vierspurig weggerissen von der A
nach einem
katastrophalen Umwelt Ereignis gesehen
wir haben gesehen und
mussten feststellen dass Menschen die in
ihren Häusern gelebt haben die in ihrer
Häuser seit anderthalb Jahren Geld
investiert haben um dort weiter wohnen
zu können dass das nicht mehr möglich
ist weil zum Beispiel erdöltanks in den
Häusern über Kopf gegangen sind und dort
die Wände verseucht haben das auch das
sind Katastrophen Katastrophen die auch
damit zusammenhängen dass eine
Infrastrukturplanung überhaupt nicht
kompatibel gemacht worden ist mit Natur
und Umweltschutz und diese Erfahrungen
benutzen wir aufgrund des herkömmlichen
Planungsrechts und der uvp-planung die
immer als Störfaktor betrachtet wird und
auch von ihnen ja so stark als der
Faktor betrachtet wird dies benutzt
worden und zu sagen genauso müssen wir
das wieder aufbauen es sind die Menschen
die in der Flut Hilfe engagiert sind und
die Arbeitsgruppen gebildet haben um uns
politischen Akteurinnen und Akteuren
deutlich Sinn machen dass das keine
kluge Antwort sein kann nach einer
Flutkatastrophe und wenn wir wissen dass
stark kriegen Ereignisse folgen dann
können wir doch nicht da wo eine ein
Fluss jetzt ein ganz harmloser Fluss
seine Kurven zieht dann können wir doch
nicht sagen wir müssen es genauso wieder
herrichten damit wir bei der nächsten
blutkatastrophe genauso wieder da stehen
ist nicht beherrschbar machen und wieder
etliche Milliarden und Millionen
investieren müssen um überhaupt Leben zu
ermöglichen in der Region da geht es um
andere Faktoren und da geht es darum
Umwelt und Naturschutz endlich den
Maßstab zu geben den er verdient ich
möchte auf ein zweites Beispiel
hinweisen die A1 Lückenschluss A1 in der
Region Adenau
die A1 Planung die
festplattenfeststellung musste erneuert
werden auch weil wiederum Akteurinnen
und Akteure aus der Zivilgesellschaft
deutlich gemacht haben dass Umwelt und
planungsrechte die das Umweltrecht
tangieren genutzt werden müssen um zum
Beispiel wasserrechtliche
Voraussetzungen zu berücksichtigen und
zum Beispiel auch dabei der Planung zu
verhindern dass es zu solchen
Katastrophen kommt das ist überhaupt
nicht eingeplant gewesen und insofern
ist Klimaschutz ist umweltschutz ist
Flächenschutz unbedingt notwendig und
ist die zivilgesellschaftliche Expertise
unbedingt notwendig um Planungsfehler zu
verhindern
ich möchte auf das Beispiel von Herrn
Spaniel eingehen der gesagt hat das wäre
doch bei lng-terminals und bei unserer
Gesetzgebung genauso gegangen und da
funktioniere das ich weiße darauf hin
dass es einen klar definierten
Ausnahmefall in diesem in dieser
Situation gab was die
verfahrensanforderungen bei LNG betraf
und das ist nicht übertragbar auf
Straßen und Brückenbau
ich komme
ich werde jetzt nicht näher eingehen auf
die verfehlte Infrastrukturpolitik es
ist ich zitiere aus 2012 Herrn groschek
oder Handy ja ich zitiere ihn einmal für
den katastrophalen Zustand der deutschen
Infrastruktur bereits 2012 es ging um
die reindrücke in Leverkusen der Mann
hat schmerzlich erfahren müssen was es
heißt viel Planung und keine Investition
zu leisten um Infrastruktur marode
Infrastruktur zu sanieren 2015 deutsches
Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung 2016
Expertenkommission damals eingesetzt von
dem damaligen Wirtschaftsminister
Gabriel es ist auch Verschleiß gefahren
worden die ganzen Jahrzehnte und das ist
jetzt
das was wir zu bearbeiten haben und das
was mir mit aller Kraft
was wir mit aller Kraft und mit allem
Engagement versuchen müssen auf Spur zu
bringen und das heißt wir bekämpfen an
dieser Stelle die Symptome und das ist
notwendig um diese Infrastruktur sicher
zu machen und um sie befahrbar zu machen
darum geht es
ihr Gesetzentwurf wird dem selbst
formulierten Anspruch überhaupt nicht
gerecht und sie fokussieren sich wieder
nur auf zwei Sachen ich habe das
eingangs erklärt Umweltrecht und
planungsphormalitäten es gibt kluge
wichtige Vorschläge die in ihre
Problemanalyse gehört hätten die tauchen
da leider nicht auf wir versuchen das
umzusetzen und deshalb an dieser Stelle
es muss dabei bleiben Klima und
Umweltschutz haben sind ein hohes Gut in
dieser Republik
Susanne Menge war das aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen in der Debatte um
über ein unionsantrag zu beschleunigten
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren für
Brücken und Fernstraßen dazu jetzt
Thomas Lutze aus der Linksfraktion wo er
verkehrspolitischer Sprecher ist
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
was die Union hier unter dem Deckmantel
des Bürokratieabbaus vorschlägt bedeutet
erstens das Begrenzen von Rechten der
Anleger und zweitens ein Beschneiden von
Mitwirkungsrechten gesellschaftlich
relevante Organisation diesen
Demokratieabbau bei Bauprojekten sogar
dazu sagen wir ganz klar und deutlich
NEIN
der Neubau und die Erweiterung von
Infrastruktur wie Autobahnen oder
Bahntrassen ist eigentlich klar geregelt
und ja Verzögerung bei Planung und Bau
sind ärgerlich für alle Beteiligten wenn
sie aber zum Beispiel aus einer
vierspurigen Autobahn bei einer
Komplettsanierung eine sechsspurige
Autobahnbrücke bauen und dann ist das
baurechtlich ein neues Bauwerk warum na
weil bei einer derartigen Vergrößerung
auch ein erhöhtes Verkehrsaufkommen
eingeplant wird sonst würde man die
Brücke ja nicht vergrößern
[Applaus]
und dieses erhöhte Verkehrsaufkommen
kann beim Umweltschutz und bei den
Rechten der Anliegen sowohl zu
gravierenden Veränderungen führen
deswegen machen wir eben genau diesen
Abbau der mitbuchungsrechte nicht mit
wenn Sie etwas für unsere zum Teil
herunterbekommen Infrastruktur machen
wollen dann müssen sie an die Belastung
der Bauwerke gehen
Autobahnbrücken müssen in der Regel nach
30 bis 40 Jahren nicht komplett saniert
werden wie das heute der Fall ist oder
komplett erneuert werden weil so viele
Autos darüber fahren sie müssen auch
nicht saniert oder erneuert werden weil
Witterung oder Temperaturschwankungen
gehen Beton angefressen haben diese
Brücken gehen kaputt weil täglich viele
tausende LKW mit bis zu 40 Tonnen
Belastung oder Gesamtgewicht darüber
fahren einer dieser LKW belastet eine
Brücke ca 60.000 mal mehr als ein 1
Tonnen schwerer PKW ihre Entscheidung
aus den 90er Jahren möglichst viel
Güterverkehr von der Bahn auf die
Autobahn zu verlagern kommt uns jetzt
teuer zu stehen
und bevor hier weiter an demokratischen
Mitwirkungsrechten herum wird sollte man
auch mal die Qualität einiger neue
Autobahnbrücken genau unter die Blume
nehmen ein Beispiel aus Thüringen bzw
bayerngefällig nach der deutschen
Einheit wurden hier die Autobahn A71 und
A73 neu geplant gebaut und
fertiggestellt bereits nach weniger als
20 Jahren musste die Talbrücke
albrechtsgraben komplett und aufwendig
saniert werden und das bei einem
Bauabschnitt mit verhältnismäßig wenigen
lkw-verkehrsauskunft da muss man doch
mal wirklich eine Fragezeichen dran
setzen sich überlegen was sie eigentlich
unserem Land bei Bauprojekt los ist an
den Mitwirkungsrechten nicht auf jeden
Fall nicht
Fazit anstatt die Mitwirkungsrechte von
anlegungen und Verbänden zur begrenzen
sollten wir uns sehr viel ernsthafter
Gedanken machen welche Mobilität wir
wollen und wir uns auch leisten können
Straßenbau und die Sanierung von Straßen
und Brücken das wissen wir alle ist sehr
teuer und aufwendig und ja wir brauchen
auch LKW um Waren und Güter im
Nahbereich anliefern zu können aber die
notwend aber der notwendige Güter
Fernverkehr quer durch Europa gehört auf
die Schiene
und in der Wirtschaftspolitik
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
müssen wir regionale
Wirtschaftskreisläufe noch viel mehr
fördern das vermeidet auch Güter
Fernverkehr und letztendlich die
Belastung unserer Autobahnbrücken denn
jeder LKW der ein Fernverkehr nicht
fahren muss entlastet unsere
Infrastruktur und das wäre dann auch
tatsächlich nachhaltend
Thomas Lutze der verkehrspolitische
Sprecher der Linksfraktion und die
nächste Rednerin wird sein Karina Conrad
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
FDP-Fraktion und wenn Sie genau
zugeguckt haben die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen eine Kameras haben es schön
eingefangen hat sie sich schon mit
Florian Müller ausgetauscht jetzt aber
erstmal das Ergebnis der namentlichen
Abstimmung
[Musik]
654 mit ja haben gestimmt 371 mit Nein
haben gestimmt 226 Enthaltungen 750
damit ist der Gesetzentwurf eines
Gesetzes zur Einführung eines
chancenaufenthaltsrechts angenommen
oder das eine namentliche Abstimmung war
im lohnt sich wahrscheinlich einen Blick
dann wenn das ganze veröffentlicht ist
auf den Seiten des Deutschen Bundestages
um dann mal zu gucken wer sich denn
tatsächlich da alles enthalten hat das
waren ja einige angekündigt auch aus den
Rhein der
cdu/csu-fraktion jetzt Karina Konrad
habe ich ihm schon gesagt hat schon
vorhin sich regelmäßig ausgetauscht mit
Florian Müller jetzt ist sie selber
ampult
Müller ich freue mich ja dass wir heute
morgen hier über so ein wichtiges Thema
wie die planungsbeschleunigung reden
können denn das ist ein wichtiges Thema
für Deutschland und ich bin wirklich
froh Herr Müller dass die Union jetzt
ihr Herz für die Planungs- und
genehmigungsbeschleunigung entdeckt hat
leider nur
bedrücken und Fernstraßen
aber ganz ehrlich ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass diese Einsicht früher
einsetzt in der Opposition die
Versäumnisse der letzten Jahre
aufzuarbeiten das mag jetzt
psychologisch für sie ein großes Ding
sein
für mich ist ihre emotionale
gesetzeseinbringung heute morgen vor
allen Dingen eins es ist ein Dokument
ihres eigenen Versagens in den letzten
Jahrzehnten
ihr Minister scheuer formulierte
Masterpläne sonder und
innovationsprogramme
2018 hat er noch behauptet mit den
rekordinvestitionen wir erinnern uns
Geld löst immer alles man müsste sich
keine Sorgen machen man habe die Brücken
im Griff was für eine Fehleinschätzung
die wir heute wissen was für eine
Fehleinschätzung und das mussten wir
erfahren es musste Volker Wissing
erfahren kurz nachdem wir hier
Verantwortung übernommen haben sie haben
die teilbrücke erwähnt diese
Vollsperrung macht uns doch erst bewusst
wie wichtig intakte
Verkehrsinfrastruktur in unserem Land
ist und diese müssen wir gewährleisten
seitdem diese Brücke gesperrt ist quälen
sich tagtäglich zehntausende Fahrzeuge
durch die Umleitungsstrecken
Anwohner sind genervt unternehmen können
lieferzeitpunkte nicht mehr einhalten
Handwerker erreichen ihre Baustellen
nicht und Krankenwagen stehen im Stau
und die Situation um Lüdenscheid herum
die ist ja kein Einzelfall in unserem
Land dieses Chaos ist die Verantwortung
ihrer Verkehrspolitik in Bund und Land
der letzten Jahre
und die Verantwortung für diese
Mangelwirtschaft jetzt von sich zu
weisen das versuchen Sie heute mit ihrem
Gesetzesentwurf hier zu machen aber
glauben Sie wirklich so könnte man
Probleme lösen glauben Sie wirklich dass
die Schuld Weitergabe ein Lösungsangebot
ist für die Menschen die sich jetzt
tagtäglich quälen müssen ich glaube das
nicht wir sind hier angetreten als Freie
Demokraten um diese Probleme zu lösen
und das ist nicht einfach für diese
Koalition ist Planungs- und
genehmigungsbeschleunigung ein zentrales
Anliegen das wird an vielen Stellen im
Koalitionsvertrag deutlich und den haben
wir alle drei unterschrieben an der
Stelle wir bauen jetzt würden ab die sie
jahrzehntelang aufgebaut haben
graviere danach wohlbedarf beim Neubau
beim Ausbau und auch beim Erhalt aller
Verkehrswege da gehören die Schienen
dazu da gehört die digitale
Infrastruktur so zu und da gehören auch
die Brücken und auch die
Bundesfernstraßen dazu und ja das heißt
auch Verkehrswege zu ertüchtigen damit
unser Land nicht Weltmeister bleibt bei
Schlaglöchern und bröckelnden Brücken
und ja dazu müssen wir auch Planung
beschleunigen und Erfolge wie man
Planung beschleunigen kann das haben wir
ja in diesem Jahr an vielen Stellen
gezeigt Frau Kollegin
furchtbar an Gott das tut mir sehr leid
das wollte ich nicht ich muss sie aber
fragen ob sie eine Zwischenfrage aus der
AFD zu hören lassen möchten nein das LG
Beschleunigungsgesetz das hat das
Potenzial offenbart was im Thema
planungsbeschleunigung steckt nach nur
sieben Monaten steht das erste
lng-terminal beim Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren haben wir einen
Paradigmenwechsel eingeleitet der
Artenschutz wird weiter gesichert und
dennoch ist ein einzelnes Tier in
Zukunft kein genehmigungshindernis mehr
wenn die Population insgesamt stabil ist
die VwGO Novelle wurde auch schon
erwähnt die Bundesjustizminister Marco
Buschmann vorgelegt hat denn auch
planungsbeschleunigung im
Verwaltungsgerichten ist dringlich und
notwendig für die zügige Umsetzung von
Infrastruktur Vorhaben und wir werden
diesen Weg weitergehen weil wir Ihnen
weitergehen müssen er wird beschwerlich
sein denn diese Knoten zu lösen die sie
gebastelt haben über die letzten
Jahrzehnte das ist nicht einfach das ist
nicht einfach und man kann auch nicht
einfach sagen man weiß es jetzt besser
weil man in der Opposition ist und
wischt mal manche Dinge einfach beiseite
so funktioniert es nicht es muss sein es
muss uns am Herzen liegen dass wir das
fernstraßenausbaugesetz angehen dass wir
die bundesschienenwege
verkehrsausbaugesetze angeben und auch
die
bundeswasserstraßenausbaugesetz angehen
denn Infrastruktur insgesamt
sicherzustellen ist zentral für die
Wirtschaften für die Zukunft unseres
Landes und wenn wir schneller werden
wollen und sie uns dabei unterstützen
dann sind Sie dazu herzlich eingeladen
aber psychologische Aufarbeitung durch
planungsbeschleunigungsvorhaben die hier
so emotional präsentiert werden und auch
fachlich so unklug gemacht sind an
vielen Stellen das bringt uns kein Meter
weiter
das wird halt Felix Schreiner für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
frau Präsidentin
meine lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen
als ich vor wenigen Wochen als
zuständiger berichterstatt an meiner
Fraktion auf Einladung von Flora Müller
und Paul ziemiak in der Region war in
Lüdenscheid die gesperrte ramedalbrücke
begutachtet habe angeschaut habe da habe
ich eine Verkehrssituation erlebt die
ich sonst noch nirgends erlebt habe aber
da sind wir uns doch einig die wir
hoffentlich nirgendwo in Deutschland so
jemals wieder erleben werden
und ich habe da eine Begegnung die ich
nie vergessen werde als ich mit einem
jungen Mann in der Lehnerstraße und von
der Bürgerinitiative A45 gesprochen hat
dann gesagt ich glaube hier an nichts
mehr ich glaube nicht mehr dran dass
hier was passiert an Wasser denn nicht
mehr glaubt dann sagt er sein einem Jahr
ist die Brücke gestört und nichts
passiert kein einzigen Schritt immer
vorangekommen und es ist doch bedrückend
das ist enttäuschend und das müssen wir
heute auch zur Kenntnis nehmen dass wir
hier ein offensichtliches Problem haben
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
und ja es ist eine Brücke die gesperrt
ist es ist eine schwierige Situation für
die Menschen aber es geht auch um mehr
diese Brücke steht für die
Glaubwürdigkeit von Politik in diesem
Land und wir müssen es hinkriegen dass
wir unsere Infrastruktur erhalten aber
auch dass wir gesperrte Brücken wieder
mit einem ersatzneubahn neu machen
können und Frau Kollegin weil sie gerade
gesagt haben naja mit der Planung und
das ist alles
so ja finde ich nicht ganz richtig ich
finde schon dass man darüber reden muss
wenn man fünf Jahre Planungsprozesse
braucht wenn man eine Lebensader in
einer Region gesperrt hat und doch
wirklich offensichtlich auch zu Kenntnis
nehmen muss dass wir hier eine Lösung
brauchen und damit sie es nicht falsch
verstehen auch ich bin sehr für
Naturschutz aber wenn ein Jahr lang
jeder Käfer gezählt und umgesiedelt wird
und am Ende aber nichts rauskommt und
wir immer noch am selben Punkt stehen
dann haben wir doch ein offensichtliches
Problem und müssen um die Prozesse gehen
und müssen einen Modus finden wie wir
die Planungsprozesse in diesem Land
beschleunigen meine Damen und Herren
der volkswirtschaftliche Schaden ist
Demenz 1,8 Milliarden Euro eine Million
am Tag und deshalb müssen wir uns noch
die Frage hier stellen und Flora Müller
hat das gesagt wenn wir in die Hand
reichen dann meinen wir das ja ernst
weil wir doch als Bundestag als
Deutscher Bundestag die Kraft haben
müssen dass wir uns um diese Themen
kümmern und dass wir die Planungs die
genehmigungs- und die
Verfahrensbeschleunigung auf dem Weg
bringen müssen und zwar gemeinsam und
dazu ist es uns übrigens gelungen dass
wir bei der beim Einsatz der
verflüssigten erst Gas beim LNG ein
gemeinsamen Antrag auf den Weg gebracht
haben wir haben das als Union
unterstützt weil es richtig war aber es
ist auch dass die Wahrheit es ist der
einzige Antrag und der einzige
Gesetzentwurf den sie als Koalition hier
in diesem Thema überhaupt auf den Weg
gebracht haben das ist leider die
bittere ähm Wahrheit sie haben einen
Entwurf wie wir der Präsident genommen
haben von Bundesverkehrsminister Volker
für den Bau von Fernstraßen er wird
derzeit blockiert von der grünen Seite
in ihrem Haus sie haben keine Kraft die
wesentlichen Infrastruktur naturprojekte
zu Beschleunigung auf den Weg zu bringen
und das ist doch auch sicherlich eine
bittere Pille die wir heute miteinander
haben dass wir eine gemeinsame
Kraftanstrengung brauchen weil wir ein
Problem haben beim Erhalt der
Infrastruktur und es geht schlichtweg
darum dass wir die wirtschaftliche
Prosperität von morgen sicherstellen und
nur wenn wir planungsbeschleunigung die
Genehmigungsverfahren dass wir den
investitions-projekte in diesem Land
umsetzen aber vor allem auch dass wir
Ersatz Neubauten umsetzen können weil
sonst werden wir mit unserer
Infrastruktur so nicht vorankommen
können wenn wir nämlich jetzt ernst
meinen und das ist doch auch was über
was wir immer im Verkehrsausschuss
diskutieren dass wir eine
klimafreundliche Mobilität von morgen
wollen hören sie auf mit kleinen
das sieht man am Beispiel der A45 ganz
genau wir müssen gemeinsam eine Lösung
für die Menschen in der betroffenen
Region bringen und dafür sind wir hier
gewählt
Felix Schreiner aus der Unionsfraktion
hat noch mal darauf verwiesen dass die
Talbrücke rahmental seit einem Jahr
gesperrt ist und hat die Glaubwürdigkeit
der Politik thematisiert am kommenden
Montag wird NRW Ministerpräsident wüst
sich ein Bild von der Lage machen zwei
Wochen später auch so berichtete sie
Westfalen Post aus Hagen auch der
cdu-parteivorsitzende und
Fraktionsvorsitzende Friedrich Merz ist
ja auch seine Heimatregion
für die SPD-Fraktion im ersten Jahr für
die Beschleunigung von Planungs und
Genehmigungsverfahren auf den Weg
gebracht hat und ich halte fest dass es
mehr als das was die Union in 12 Jahren
Verkehrsministerium geschaffen hat
warum machen wir das weil die
Modernisierung unseres Landes keinen
Aufschub duldet weil es um den Erhalt
der natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen geht
weil es um die Sicherheit der
Energieversorgung geht und weil wir das
nur schaffen werden wenn wir neue
Technologien und eine moderne
Infrastruktur hinbekommen und deswegen
handelt die Koalition auch vom ersten
Tag an der Regierungsübernahme
umfangreiche Pakete haben den Bundestag
bereits passiert oder sind im
Geschäftsgang das liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist nicht das Ende sondern erst
der Anfang
denn viele Menschen in unserem Land sind
frustriert von ewigen und kostspieligen
Baustellen von fehlender Digitalisierung
auf dem Bürgeramt von verspäteten und
überteuerten Zügen von fehlenden
Mobilfunknetz von schlechtem Internet
die Beschleunigung von Planungs- und
genehmigungs-
im Frühjahr haben wir uns um die massive
Beschleunigung der erneuerbaren Energien
gekümmert dazu gehört die Festschreibung
des überragenden öffentlichen Interesses
der erneuerbaren Energien und des
Netzausbaus so wie die Einführung
verbindlicher flächenziele für Windkraft
an Land Schluss gemacht haben wir
hingegen mit der 10h Abstandsregel
sozusagen ihr bayerisches
Herzensanliegen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen im weiteren Verlauf des Jahres
haben wir auch Anpassungen beim
Artenschutz vorgenommen nicht durch
Absenkung des Schutzes wie die Kollegin
ausgeführt hat sondern durch
Standardisierung das ist ein gelungener
Ausgleich von Arten und Klimaschutz
lassen sie uns mehr Pragmatismus wagen
wir beenden mit einer weiteren
Gesetzesinitiative die unnötigen
Doppelprüfungen zwischen sich
überschneidenden Planungsverfahren
ebenso haben wir die in der Pandemie
bewertet digitale Bürgerbeteiligung
verlängert als in diesem Jahr letzter
Baustein unserer beschleunigungspakete
hat das Kabinett am Mittwoch einen
Beschluss zur Änderung der
Verwaltungsgerichtsordnung und weiterer
Gesetze gefasst hiermit soll im
gerichtlichen Verfahren großer
Infrastrukturprojekte Vorfahrt gegeben
werden Behörden werden Fristen gesetzt
für
klageerwiderungen nicht jeder formelle
Fehler behindert dem
vorbeugenden Rechtsschutz eine schnelle
gerichtliche konfliktbewilligung wird
damit gestärkt das liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist eine gute Nachricht
aber bei den bisher aufgezählten
Maßnahmen kann und wird es nicht bleiben
neben weiteren beschleunigungspaketen
zum Beispiel im Bereich Verkehr brauchen
wir mehr Personal eine flexible
behördeninfrastruktur und die
vollständige Digitalisierung des
antragswesens denn die Beschleunigung
beginnt beim Kampf gegen Leitzordner und
Aktenberge
die im Gesetzesentwurf vorgeschlagenen
Ausnahmen von der Umwelt
Verträglichkeitsprüfung für Brücken
verkennen hingegen Europa rechtliche
Hürden denn die Ausnahmen von der
UVP-Pflicht werden sehr streng und
restriktiv ausgelegt dazu gehören
meistens Katastrophenfälle wie zum
Beispiel die Möglichkeit einer Energie
Mangellage Beschleunigung liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen darf für die
Politik jedoch niemals bedeuten
rechtswidrige Entscheidungen zu
produzieren denn das wäre das Modell
scheuer
ich stimme der Union allerdings zu nicht
jede Maßnahme an einer Brücke braucht
unbedingt eine
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung wir müssen
dann als Gesetzgeber allerdings schon
regeln wo die Grenze zwischen
Bauerneuerung und Verbesserung verläuft
wann wir eine Prüfung brauchen und wann
nicht sie hingegen schlawinern und
dieses Thema herum in dem Sie es mit
einer Verordnungsermächtigung regeln
wollen und das liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen da habe ich meine Zweifel ob
das nach einem Verkehrsminister an die
Steuer eine gute Idee ist in der letzten
Zeit hat der Kollege Ploss ebenfalls
kritisiert dass die Ampel
eher am Verbandsklagerecht festhalte als
an der planungsbeschleunigung seine
Lösung des Verbandsklagerecht
einzuschränken auch dieser Vorschlag und
das wissen sie ist europarechtswidrig
und wenn sie ehrlich sind haben sie die
Urteile des eughs aus 2015 schon zur
Kenntnis genommen was wir als Koalition
allerdings tun und das sollten Sie auch
zur Kenntnis nehmen ist eine
europa-rechtskonformelösung zu finden
das Justizministerium schlägt deswegen
vor wer im weiteren Verlauf eines
Prozesses auf gerichtliche Frist ein
Argument nicht eingebracht hat der
sollte dann ausgeschlossen sein das ist
ein pragmatischer
europa-rechtskonformerweg es finden sich
weitere Vorschläge auch im Bund
länderpapier lassen Sie mich
zusammenfassen es ist gut dass wir in
den Zielen übereinstimmen die Ampel
bringt eingesetzt nach dem anderen ein
und Planungsverfahren zu beschleunigen
Sie hingegen beschleunigen nur das Tempo
haltbarer Vorschläge ich danke Ihnen für
die Aufmerksamkeit
für die AFD hat René Bochmann das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer auf den
Tribünen an den Fernsehgeräten
wir der platzieren heute in der ersten
Beratung über den von der cdu/csu
eingebrachten Entwurf des Gesetzes zur
weiteren Beschleunigung von Planungs-
und Genehmigungsverfahren an Brücken auf
bundesamtsstraßen
insbesondere bemängelt dabei die Union
die langen Zeiträume für notwendige
Planungsverfahren das Paradoxe und etwas
lustige dabei ist dass sie zur
Beseitigung dieser Missstände mehr als
zwölf Jahre Zeit hatten und die dafür
verantwortlichen Minister stellten
beispielhaft erwähnen sie in ihrem
Antrag die Sperrung der Talbrücke ramede
der Bundesautobahn 45 im dezember 2021
dabei geht es hier um viel mehr
4000 Brücken sind sanierungsbedürftig
ich wiederhole 4000 Brücken
die Bewertung erfolgt seit kurzem durch
sogenannte lastmodelle die Zustand und
Tragfähigkeit der Brücke beschreiben
ähnlich wie bei Schulnoten beschreiben
LM1 bis lm5 den aktuellen brückenzustand
LM1 steht für keine Abweichung lm5 für
absolut kaputt mit lm5 sind ca 16%
dieser Autobahn und bundesstraßenbrücken
in der Art schlechten Zustand das ist
der Stand des brückengipfels im März
diesen Jahres und gleichzeitig Resultat
ihre jahrelangen Vernachlässigung
unserer Verkehrsinfrastruktur gleiches
geht auch für die deutschen
Bundeswasserstraßen mit maroden
Schleusen und die Bahn mit schadhaften
Bahntrassen ein weiteres Beispiel für
diese Misswirtschaft ist die Rate
Hochbrücke über den Nord-Ostsee-Kanal
2018 antwortete die Bundesregierung
unter der Drucksache
19/726 auf die Kleine Anfrage des
damaligen Bundestagsabgeordneten
andreassek und der afd-fraktion ich
zitiere mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin
eine statische Nachrechnung der
bestehenden Rader Hochbrücke ergab dass
das Bauwerk erneuert werden muss die
Vorplanung für das ersatzbauwerk wurde
Anfang 2015 begonnen meine einzelanfrage
409 im Februar 22 zum gleichen
Sachverhalt Rader Hochbrücke also vier
Jahre später ergab fast die gleiche
Antwort die gesamte
Verkehrsinfrastruktur wurde
unverantwortlich und systematisch
vernachlässigt
hinzu kommen immer wieder Blockaden der
Umweltverbände die zu weiteren unnötigen
Verzögerungen Kostenexplosionen führen
beim Anschluss der Bundesstraße 6N an
die Bundesautobahn 9 ist es
beispielsweise die Knoblauchkröte
unfassbar
auch unter der Ampel hat sich bisher
nicht zum Besseren geändert wie die
geplante Nutzung der innerstädtischen
Berliner Parkplätze an Bundesfernstraßen
als Abstellfläche für Fahrräder oder der
Stillstand beim Autobahn Neubau der
Bundesautobahn 100 zeigen deshalb
stimmen wir diesem Antrag zu oder fragen
Sie ganz einfach doch mal ihr
Navigationssystem die wir jetzt am
schnellsten ans Ziel kommen es wird
wahrscheinlich die AFD empfehlen vielen
Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit ich wünsche
Ihnen allen einen angenehmes Wochenende
einen schönen zweiten Advent
bevor ich
die nächsten Redner das Wort gebe möchte
ich sie gerne darauf hinweisen dass wir
eine weitere namentliche Abstimmung
haben werden und zwar zur top
32A so dass ich alle schon einmal darauf
einstellen können alles andere wird
Ihnen dann noch genauer bekannt gegeben
jetzt hat Lukas Benner das Wort für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Wiederaufbau nach dem Hochwasser aus dem
vergangenen Jahr der Aufbau Klima
resilienter Städte der Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine und die dadurch
ausbleibenden Gaslieferung wir stehen
vor riesigen Herausforderungen was
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren
angeht die Klimakrise die Energiekrise
die Überbleibsel der corona-pandemie all
das stellt unsere Behörden vor riesige
Herausforderungen ihre Antwort Liebe
Union die Schaffung des überragenden
öffentlichen Interesses für Bundeswehr
Fernstraßen
im ganzen Land zerfallen die Brücken
weil sie und ihre Verkehrsminister die
letzten zwölf Jahre mit flugtaxis und
rechtswidrigen mautverfahren beschäftigt
waren anstatt endlich das Problem
anzugehen
fast nirgends wird das so deutlich wie
bei der schon erwähnten
rahmendetalbrücke die Kosten für die
Sperrung sind Milliarden aber liebe
Union wer hat uns denn den Murks
eingeborgt ihre Kritik ist wohl File an
dieser Stelle und ich möchte betonen
niemand leugnet dass wir eine schnellere
Sanierung von Brücken brauchen ich bin
in der Eifel groß geworden wir brauchen
Sie nicht zu sagen dass wir eine
vernünftige Verkehrsinfrastruktur
brauchen gerade dort wo wir noch keinen
ÖPNV und keine Alternativen haben aber
nicht so wie sie in ihrem Antrag
schreiben
wir als Ampelkoalition haben uns das
Thema Planungs- und
genehmigungsbeschleunigung ganz nach
oben geschrieben am Mittwoch war die
VwGO bereits im Kabinett und ich kann
Ihnen sagen es werden noch viele Gesetze
folgen dass wir im Jahr 2022 immer noch
zig Aktenordner brauchen um eine
Windkraftanlage zu genehmigen ist
völliger Öse für uns grünes klar bei der
Beschleunigung von neubauinfrastruktur
brauchen wir ganz klare Priorisierung
wer alles beschleunigen will
beschleunigt am Ende gar nichts und
deswegen muss es zum Wind Energie
Stromtrassen Bahnstrecken gehen und
nicht primär um Autobahnen und Flughäfen
denn es geht darum Energie Souveränität
herzustellen und nachhaltige
funktionierende Infrastruktur Thema
Nachhaltigkeit in ihrem Antrag kommt das
Wort Schadstoffbelastung genau einmal
vor und zwar bei der Begründung um noch
breitere Straßen zu bauen der zweite
wichtige Punkt bei
planungsbeschleunigung ist zu betonen
das Umweltschutz nicht das Problem ist
nicht Feldhamster und Rotmilan
verhindern Planungen in diesem Land
sondern Faxgeräte und mangelndes
Personal deswegen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lassen sie uns aufhören
Gegensätze aufzumachen die unmittelbaren
Reform müssen Ziel genau sein und
anstatt falscher Gegensätze die häufig
mehr Klischee als Realität sind sollten
wir anpacken und pragmatisch sein vielen
Dank
Lukas Benner war das für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen hier geht es
weiter um Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren an Brücken und
Fernstraßen dazu jetzt Christian Hirte
aus der Union
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen viele der Vorredner haben
darauf hingewiesen dass wir ein akutes
Problem haben und zwar nicht nur bei der
Brücke an bei Lüdenscheid sondern auch
bei vielen anderen
infrastrukturpolitischen Themen wir
haben die 4000 Brücken die saniert
werden müssen viele Straßen und andere
Infrastrukturprojekte viele bestätigen
dass aber wenn wir gerade gehört haben
von dem Redner der Grünen das wir als
Union falsch darauf reagiert haben in
der Vergangenheit dann zeigt es doch
eher bei ihnen dass sie ideologisch mit
der Situation umgehen wenn Sie meinen
dass wir heute nur punktuell an der ein
oder anderen Stelle etwas erreichen
wollen das Gegenteil ist der Fall sie
erkennen dass wir an einigen Punkten
schneller werden müssen Beispiele waren
schon gesagt sondern für der schnelle
Ausbau des LG Terminals das unterstützen
wir als Union weil wir das für richtig
erachten aber auf der anderen Seite sind
wir in einer so herausragenden Krise in
Deutschland in unserem Land
aufgrund lang sich aufgebauter Probleme
aber auch aufgrund der aktuellen
Krisensituation durch den Krieg in
Europa und die großen
Transformationsprozesse dass wir in
nahezu jedem Bereich schneller besser
werden müssen jetzt war es so in der
Vergangenheit dass wir in Deutschland
gerade nicht dafür berühmt waren dass
wir beim Thema Pragmatismus und Tempo
gut waren warum das so ist haben wir von
einigen Rednern jetzt gerade gehört sie
Lehne schlicht ab das was möglich wäre
auf den Weg zu bringen und tatsächlich
ist es doch so lieber Kollege Müller
dass wir nicht nur zum Beispiel bei dem
Infrastrukturprojekt im Watt wo wir im
weltnatur Erbe neue Infrastrukturen ganz
schnell mit abgekürzten
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung auf den
Weg bringen sondern das ist auch ein
anderen Bereichen machen können und
genau das ist die Forderung der
cdu/csu-fraktion dass wir eben schauen
muss noch notwendig ist zum Beispiel
auch bei Straßenbauprojekten
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei
den transformationsherausforderungen in
unserem Land geht es eben nicht nur
darum die Energieinfrastruktur auf den
Weg zu bringen sondern auch die
restliche Infrastruktur hören wir ja
gelegentlich aber das was bei ihnen
passiert ist leider zu wenig wir als
Union machen einen konkreten Vorschlag
wir unterstützen nicht nur das was sie
richtigerweise auf den Weg bringen
sondern wir machen bessere darüber
hinausgehende Vorschläge zum Beispiel
auch für die Bundesstraßen um die
Beschleunigung vor allem von Verfahren
und die Vereinfachung von Verfahren zu
ermöglichen
wir haben die Situation dass das
aktuelle
umweltrechtsverhelfsgesetz eben die
Verbandsklagen ermöglicht dass die aber
häufig instrumentalisiert
missbraucht werden für die Wahrnehmung
von partikular von Einzelinteressen vor
Ort das ist der falsche Weg wir müssen
schneller werden wir müssen Verfahren
abkürzen vereinbaren und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wann wenn ich
jetzt dieses an der Zeit Gas zu geben
und unser Land voranzubringen vielen
Dank
Reuter ist der nächste Redner für die
FDP-Fraktion und in der FDP-Fraktion ist
der verkehrspolitischer Sprecher
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren Kollege Müller ich fange mal mit
was positivem an es gibt ja ein
bekanntes Lied in dem es heißt mein Herz
schlägt für das Sauerland und gleich
spricht ja auch noch der Kollege ziemiak
und ich will euch ja nicht absprechen
dass euer Herz für diese Region schlägt
aber auch das Herz der Freien Demokraten
schlägt für das Sauerland das zeigt
allein die Tatsache das zeigt allein die
Tatsache dass Minister Volker Wissing
die rabedetalbrücke zur Chefsache
gemacht hat ich glaube es gibt keinen
Infrastrukturprojekt in diesem Land wo
so viele hochrangige Vertreter des
Ministeriums der Minister voran mal vor
Ort gewesen sind mit den Menschen vor
Ort gesprochen haben und ihnen
versprochen haben dass sie sich bei
diesem Projekt schnellstmöglichst
kümmern und dieses Projekt
schnellstmöglich nach allen Regeln der
Kunst umgesetzt wird
[Applaus]
aber zur Wahrheit gehört auch Kollege
Berkan hat es angesprochen wir hätten
schon längst dort an der A45 eine neue
Brücke haben können das muss man einfach
mal so konzertieren und jetzt will ich
auch noch mal einmal hört gut zu die
große Koalition loben weil vor vielen
Jahren ist die Autobahn GmbH auf den Weg
gebracht worden da ist dafür gesorgt
worden dass nicht mehr die Länder die
das alle ganz ganz unterschiedlich
geregelt haben die das alle ganz
unterschiedlich geregelt haben
jetzt die Autobahn GmbH zuständig ist
und Minister Volker Wissing hat dann ja
am Beginn diesen Jahres hat dann ja am
Beginn dieses Jahres und jetzt können
wir endlich mal konnten wir endlich mal
eine einheitliche Überprüfung der
gesamten Autobahnbrücken in diesem Land
vornehmen und das hat viel Trauriges zu
Tage gefördert 4000 Autobahnbrücken in
diesem Land sind
sanierungsbedürftig diese Koalition
diese Regierungsfraktion geht mit
Hochdruck mit Hochdruck an dass zu
sanieren und
schnellstmöglich auf den Weg zu bringen
und ich will
und ich will jetzt noch mal eins sagen
hier wurde ja jetzt gerade auch von den
Kollegen auch Kollege schreinerharz
erwähnt von handreichen gesprochen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union ihr
habt in der letzten
Wahlperiode mehrere Gesetze zur
planungsbeschleunigung auf den Weg
gebracht da haben wir als Freie
Demokraten Vorschläge gemacht die ihr
jetzt genau in euren Gesetzentwurf
geschrieben haben wir haben euch damals
die Hand gereicht ihr habt sie nicht
ergriffen in der letzten Wahlperiode das
gehört auch dazu ihr habt mich ergriffen
jetzt
ihr habt ihr habt ihr habt das nicht
ergriffen und die Bundesregierung wird
ein Gesetz vorlegen die viele dieser
Punkte die wir schon in der letzten
Wahlperiode
vorgeschlagen haben jetzt aufgreifen was
Priorisierung von wichtigen
Infrastrukturen angeht was
doppelüberprüfungen abschaffen angeht
was Bürger und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
Bürger und Öffentlichkeitsbeteiligung
garantiert von Beginn an ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Punkt das Ping Pong zwischen
Landes und Bundesbehörden beenden den
digitalen Datenfluss sicherstellen
building Information modeling dabei
haben das ist ein ganz ganz wichtiger
Punkt und wir wollen das Thema LG
wie war es jetzt gemacht haben zu einem
Standard machen in dieser
Bundesregierung nicht nur für
lng-terminals sondern auch für
verschiedene für Wasserstraße für
Bundesfernstraßen für Brücken das muss
alles mit dabei sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
Union sie haben jahrelang gebummelt wir
machen jetzt Geschwindigkeit vielen
herzlichen Dank
Bernd Reuter war das der
verkehrspolitische Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion und weil er hier ein Titel
aus dem Jahr 1984 der Gruppe Zoff nur
ein bisschen halbherzig zitiert wollen
wir dann noch mal ein bisschen
nachhelfen Sauerland mein Herz schlägt
für das Sauerland begrab mich mal am
Lenne Strand wo die Misthaufen qualmen
da gibt's keine Palmen jetzt Martina
Engel hat Kopf aus der Unionsfraktion
die Umsetzung von wichtigen
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen in unserem Land
muss deutlich schneller gehen und
es dauert einfach zu lange Jahre
Jahrzehnte es wird vieles blockiert und
verhindert und daraus müssen wir auch
endlich endlich unsere Lehren ziehen als
expertnation und Transitland im Herzen
Europas sind wir auf eine gut
funktionierende Infrastruktur auf ein
gutes Verkehrsnetz angewiesen es ist und
nicht verzichtbar für unsere Wirtschaft
für das wirtschaftliche Handeln aber
auch für die Mobilität der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger 70% der gesamt
Verkehrsleistungen laufen über die
Straße und das ist einfach ein Fakt den
wir heute auch ganz klar bewerten müssen
und deshalb brauchen wir eine Zukunft
nicht nur kräftige Investitionen ich
denke hier an die Drohne Auflösung des
finanzierungskreislauf auf der Straße
finanziert Straße ein völlig verteileres
Zeichen die Amp lässt sich hierüber
darauf bereits einig wir dürfen uns aber
anders als auch den Luxus langwieriger
Verfahren nicht länger leisten denn
Mobilität in der Zukunft wird auch egal
welche Antriebstechnologien wir haben
auf der Straße mit stattfinden müssen
und wir leben gegenwärtig in multiple
und Krisenzeiten dynamischen
Veränderungen tagtäglich passiert neues
aufgrund dessen müssen wir hier einfach
unsere Infrastruktur weiter ertüchtigen
das Ganze vor diesem Hintergrund auch
betrachten deshalb folgende Konsequenz
an dieser Stelle Infrastruktur muss
allgemein in das überragende öffentliche
Interesse auch
Bundesfernstraßen sind Lebensadern
darauf darüber laufen Güter und
Transporte aber auch die Mobilität für
unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger in der
aktuellen Periode ist bisher wenig
passiert in diesem Bereich wenn wir in
das Bundesverkehrsministerium blicken in
der Vergangenheit auch mit Unterstützung
der SPD wurden viele
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetze auf den
Weg gebracht aber wir dürfen hier nicht
nachlassen wir müssen schneller werden
es muss viel schneller auch entsprechend
hier die Infrastruktur angepasst werden
und dafür gibt es ja auch ein gutes
Beispiel aus der Praxis dass es eben
doch gehen kann es wurde heute bereits
das Beschleunigungsgesetz für LNG
angesprochen und nach diesem Vorbild
müssen wir auch weiter voranschreiten
als Grundlage die FDP hat das soeben
angesprochen aber wenn ich richtig
informiert bin liebe FDP konnten sie
sich auch nicht durchsetzen bei der
Verkürzung der Gerichtsverfahren dass
eben Straßen Bundes Fernstraßen in das
überragende öffentliche Interesse kommen
es wurde gestrichen somit gelten hier
verkürzt die Gericht zu fahren nicht das
ist Fakt die Meldung vom ersten Dezember
das sei an dieser Stelle auch erwähnt
wenn Sie hier solche großen Töne spucken
dass diese beschleunigten Verfahren
künftig auch als Grundlage verwendet
werden sollen
wie es schneller gehen kann dafür
liefert unser Gesetz viele wertvolle
Ansätze greifen sie an damit wir unsere
Infrastruktur fit machen für die Zukunft
besser heute als morgen herzlichen Dank
Martina Engelhardt Kopf aus der Union
Fraktion sie ist mit dem
Verkehrsausschuss und die nächste
Rednerin ist Mitglied immer
Rechtsausschuss denn gerechtfragen
spielen natürlich eine wichtige Rolle
Sander Martens aus der SPD-Fraktion frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der demokratischen Parteien es
ist interessant über einen Antrag der
Union zu sprechen der sich mit
Geschwindigkeit befasst leider sind sie
bei ihrem Gesetzentwurf mit hoher
Geschwindigkeit bereits aus der ersten
Kurve geflogen im wesentlichen Teilen
haben sie bei genauem Hinsehen nämlich
nichts anderes getan als das von uns
verabschiedete LNG Beschleunigungsgesetz
zu kopieren aber sie haben es
offensichtlich versäumt sich die
wesentlichen Unterschiede zwischen
kritischer Energieinfrastruktur oder
eine Autobahnbrücke klar zu machen
zunächst ist zu begrüßen dass sie im § 3
ihres Gesetzesvorschlags eine Änderung
des fernstraßenbaugesetzes anregen die
einen instandhaltungsplan schaffen soll
bedauerlich nur dass Ihnen dieser
zwingende Gedanke nicht bereits in der
letzten Dekade gekommen ist immerhin
sind sie in den letzten 12 nicht 16
Jahren vier verschiedene Bundesminister
einer christozialen Regionalpartei im
Verkehrsministerium verschlissen worden
verwunderlich die Zielrichtung dieses
instandhaltungsplans hier schlagen sie
nämlich vor dass die Sanierung der im
Plan genannten Bauvorhaben teilweise
oder ganz von der
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung
ausgenommen werden soll
derartige Einschnitte sind im Fall von
kritischer Energieinfrastruktur
bedauerlich aufgrund der wenigen Fälle
aber vielleicht noch verkraftbar im Fall
von Bundesfernstraßen und Brücken kommt
ihr Vorschlag hingegen einer
grundsätzlichen Schleifung der
Umweltverträglichkeit gleich
schlimmer noch mit jeder gesetzeskopie
navigieren sie blind in den
Geltungsbereich des Europarechts und das
auch noch wieder besseres Wissens oder
wenn in der Begründung zum
Gesetzesentwurf erläutern sie ausgiebig
das gemäß EU-Recht und ständiger
Rechtsprechung des Europäischen
Gerichtshofs das Aufsetzen von
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen für den
Bau und in weiten Teilen auch für die
Instandhaltung von Bundesfernstraßen und
notwendigen Brücken nicht möglich ist
man hätte doch annehmen können dass die
Union gerade im verkehrspolitischen
Bereich ausreichend Erfahrung mit dem
Europarecht gesammelt hat Stichwort
Pkw-Maut
insofern verwundert mich dass Sie mit
dem vorliegenden Gesetzentwurf erneut
eine Klatsche vor dem Europäischen
Gerichtshof riskieren nicht verwundert
mich hingegen dass sie ihren
fragwürdigen Umgang mit dem geltenden
Recht gleich auch noch auf das
Bundesnaturschutzgesetz übertragen so
schlagen Sie vor die Fristen zur
Genehmigung und zum umsetzungsbeginn von
Ersatz und Ausgleichsmaßnahmen auf
insgesamt fünf Jahre auszudehnen auch
das eine Kopie aus dem LNG
Beschleunigungsgesetz was sie immerhin
in der Begründung kenntlich machen wo
sich aber der Anwendungsbereich des
lng-gesetzes auf insgesamt vier
Terminals beschränkt umfasst der
Anwendungsbereich ihres Vorschlags
zigtausende Kilometer Bundesfernstraßen
und Brücken und vergleichbare
Bauprojekte Definition offen und Anzahl
unbekannt was hier deutlich wird vier
Terminals lassen sich keinesfalls mit
dem gesamtdeutschen Bundes-
selbiges gilt auch für Ihren Vorschlag
des Gesetzes gegen
Wettbewerbsbeschränkungen zu beschneiden
und zwar darf ihmgehend das
mittelständische Interessen bei der
Vergabe öffentlicher Aufträge nicht mehr
vornehmlich berücksichtigt werden sollen
es ist doch überraschend dass die Union
sich immer mehr nicht mehr als die
Partei des Mittelstandes darstellt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union wie
mein Kollege Jürgen Beran bereits
erläutert hat arbeiten die
Bundesregierung und unsere Fraktionen
gerade em sich an einem
Gesetzesvorschlag zu Beschleunigung von
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren in
der Beratung des Gesetzentwurfs freuen
wir uns selbstredend auf Ihre
konstruktive Zuarbeit bis dahin aber
auch für weitere Zukunft möchte ich Sie
jedoch bitten so sehr Ihnen beim
Schreiben ihre Anträge die
Geschwindigkeit am Herzen liegen mag so
sehr kann es doch lohnenswert sein beim
Abschreiben zumindest kurz über
Fliehkraft und Kurvengeschwindigkeit und
somit den Inhalt zu reflektieren gute
Fahrt
Sander Martens war das aus der
SPD-Fraktion und der nächste Regner
kennt sich aus falls hier noch mal das
Thema rahmendetalbrücke bei Lüdenscheid
kommen sollte paul ziemiak ist das
nämlich neuerdings Generalsekretär der
CDU in
Nordrhein-Westfalen und hat sein
Wahlkreis im Märkischen Kreis in
Deutschland hat einen Infarkt der Lippen
und es begann ein großer Horror für die
Menschen in Lüdenscheid im Sauerland im
Märkischen Kreis in ganz Südwestfalen
die Menschen leiden unter dieser
Situation wenn Ihnen jeden Tag 40 Tonner
an ihren Schlafzimmerfenstern vorbei
donnern dann werden sie am Ende krank
das ist Körperverletzung was viele an
den Umleitungsstrecken jetzt erleben und
es ist eine große Belastung für die
gesamte Region
und wir haben diese Situation bisher
gemeinsam bewältigt und aus dieser
schlimmen Situation noch versucht das
Beste zu machen aber wir sind in großer
Sorge über die Zukunft
und Herr Minister Wissing ist heute da
ich will an dieser Stelle das sagen das
ist ja keine Selbstverständlichkeit bei
dieser ampelregierung dass bei wichtigen
Themen die Minister sich auch blicken
lassen sie tun es heute und sind da das
ist gut und ich weiß auch dass dem
Minister dass ein Anliegen ist sie waren
vor Ort Herr Minister sie setzen sich
ein wir sind dazu im Gespräch aber sie
haben heute auch in der Westfalenpost in
einem Interview richtig gesagt alles was
es an Ideen gibt muss auch rechtlich
einer rechtlichen Überprüfung
standhalten damit hat der Minister Recht
und deswegen legen wir heute diesen
Vorschlag vor damit die Rahmede
teilbrücke so schnell wie möglich wieder
neu gebaut werden kann und die Menschen
endlich entlastet werden können meine
Damen und Herren
und ich war heute sehr gespannt auf Ihre
Vorschläge die sie einbringen weil ich
finde das ist keine parteipolitische
Frage auch vor Ort arbeiten wir alle
zusammen sondern eine Fraktion in diesem
Fall CDU und CSU legen ein Vorschlag vor
und ich war jetzt gespannt was haben Sie
denn für Ideen was haben wir vielleicht
nicht so gut gemacht was kann man besser
machen was fehlt noch damit die Brücken
diese Brücke und andere noch schnell
aufgebaut werden können und dann höre
ich hier einfach blanke
Ignoranz AFD sagt Merkel die Schuld die
Grünen sagen die Brücke kann jetzt nicht
beschleunigt wegen der globalen
Klimakrise SPD sagt wir machen jetzt
erstmal gar nichts linke guckt die ganze
Zeit aufs Handy und so blütenscheid äh
so das ist ja aber das ist doch keine
das ist doch keine Haltung geben Sie
doch Ihre Ideen ein damit wir ein noch
besseres Gesetz einbringen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren das ist
übrigens es gibt zwei Zwischenfragen
Wünsche möchten Sie einen beide zulassen
es geht um die Sache und deswegen bin
ich auf ja bin ich dann natürlich
stellen sie doch mal eine Zwischenfrage
wie die Kolleginnen und plappern sie
nicht dazwischen
aber danke
an der Stelle haben sie auch recht aber
nicht nur an der also jetzt werde erst
mal dran und dann
[Musik]
frau Präsidentin vielen dank vielen Dank
Herr Kollege Zwischenfrage zulassen sie
haben davon erzählt wie schwierig die
Situation vor Ort ist das wissen wir
denke ich auch sauerländische
Abgeordnete die vor Ort sind übrigens
auch von der SPD schlägt das Herz für
das Sauerland das möchte ich hier an
dieser Stelle mal festhalten ich möchte
sie ganz gerne fragen ist Ihnen
eigentlich bekannt das ist ein
Beschlussvorschlag gibt es
Bundeskanzleramts zusammen mit den Chefs
der Kanzleien der Länder genau über
diesen Punkt und zwar mit der
Überschrift packt für
planungsgenehmigungs- und
umsetzungsbeschleunigung vom 14 vom 17
November und genau darin hätte sie mir
sind nämlich unsere Vorschläge schon
längst drin enthalten und da kommen wir
nämlich Bund und Land zusammen sie
stellen das ja hier so da als wenn hier
überhaupt nichts laufen würde ich würde
sie wirklich einladen wirklich auch mal
aktuell zur Brücke zu gehen und zu
schauen wie dort nämlich gearbeitet wird
und bitte stellen Sie auch klar dass das
Problem nicht der Brückenbau ist sondern
dass die Umleitungsstrecken das Problem
sind und da ist die schwarz-grüne
Landesregierung in der Pflicht und wenn
Sie hier Polemik machen dass es Horror
nämlich dort für die Anwohnerinnen und
Anwohner jetzt nehme ich gleich noch die
Frage von Frau Menge dazu und dann kann
Herr ziemiak der sich gut Dinge merken
kann dass im
Kontext beantworten und dann in die
Schlusskurve seiner Rede kommen da ist
nämlich gar nicht mehr so viel übrig
Dankeschön Herr ziemiak dass sie die
Frage zulassen sie haben gesagt dass sie
hier keine Vorschläge gehört haben dass
niemand etwas zu konkreten Umsetzungen
gesagt hat ich möchte Sie daran erinnern
dass vor allen Dingen der Kollege man
Suri einzelne Vorschläge vorgelegt hat
die vor allen Dingen mit
planungseffizienz zu tun haben die mit
planungsmanagement zu tun haben wir
haben gesagt wo sie vielleicht in ihrem
Gesetzesvorschlag falsch liegen weil
bestimmte rechtliche Vorgaben nicht
eingehalten werden meine Kollegen haben
vor allen Dingen der Kollege werner hat
darauf hingewiesen was machbar und
umsetzbar ist warum
ignorieren sie das an der Stelle
vielen Dank für die Zwischenfragen
zunächst einmal Frau Kollegin es ist bei
der Frage der Beschleunigung der
Besprechung zwischen dem
Bundeskanzleramt und den Ländern wenn
ich es richtig sehe steht es jetzt auch
nicht mehr auf der Tagesordnung für die
nächste MPK vielleicht können Sie dazu
was sagen woran das woran das liegt das
werden sie wissen also es geht mir nicht
schnell genug ich will dass ihnen ganz
ehrlich sagen und sie haben sie haben
gerade sie haben sie haben gerade gesagt
ich sollte zu der Brücke kommen an der
ich schon häufig war und mir anschauen
was dort alles passiert dann arbeiten
wissen sie die Menschen haben nichts
davon in Lüdenscheid und den Märkischen
Kreis wenn Sie sich anschauen wieder
Baggerfahrt die Menschen interessiert
nur eins wann steht endlich wieder die
neue Brücke damit dieser Verkehr raus
ist aus der Stadt und der Region wieder
leben kann bringt doch nichts wenn wir
die ganze Zeit darüber diskutieren wie
viel Bagger da sind das ist die einfache
Frage und ich finde und jetzt haben Sie
noch ein jetzt haben Sie noch etwas
gesagt jetzt haben sie gesagt wer ist
schuld wer wer ist schuld an was wer
trägt welche sehr gerne diskutieren nur
wissen sie das ist keine ja das ist der
Unterschied zwischen Sauerland in
Handwerkern den Unternehmen den Menschen
im Sauerland und manchen hier im
Deutschen Bundestag immer dieses auf
andere zeigen da gibt es Probleme nur
nicht sagen wie es gehen kann und das
ist nicht meine Mentalität und ich würde
Ihnen auch wünschen dass auch sie in der
SPD mehr sauerländische Mentalität haben
mal anzupacken und nicht nur die Schuld
auf andere zu schieben
und dann
zu der Frage zu der zu der Frage der
Grünen also ihre Vorschläge sind ja
insofern keine konstruktiven Vorschläge
weil sie ja nicht ein sie wollen ja
jetzt grundsätzlich nicht mit diesem
Gesetzesvorschlag arbeiten das würde ich
mir aber sehr wünschen und Sie haben
gerade selbst davon gesprochen wegen des
Klimaschutzes und wegen der Interessen
der Anwohnerinnen und Anwohner könnten
wir jetzt nicht so das Planungsrecht
ändern ich sage Ihnen also erstens diese
Autobahnbrücke verursacht vor allem die
Emission dadurch dass die LKWs und die
Autos sich durch die Stadt quetschen die
Menschen sind belastet durch die Abgase
es geht keine Hochwassergefahr aus von
dieser Brücke und wissen Sie wenn Sie
über die Interessen und Interessen der
Anwohnerinnen und Anwohner sprechen ich
kenne keinen einzigen der will dass
dieser Zustand lange erhalten bleibt
also wenn sie von den Anliegen der
Menschen in der synchron sprechen dann
wissen Sie was zu tun ist so schnell wie
möglich muss diese Brücke gebaut werden
und das ist der Grund warum Florian
Müller und alle anderen
Verkehrspolitiker und wir gemeinsam hier
diesen Antrag diesen Gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt haben
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wer in Südwestfalen wir im Märkischen
Kreis wir brauchen Ihre Hilfe damit wir
endlich entlastet werden seien sie
konstruktiv denken Sie nicht in
Parteigrenzen sondern lassen Sie uns
zusammenarbeiten dass wir möglichst
schnell das Ding hochziehen und ist
unsere Region wieder richtig stark leben
kann damit wir weiter in unseren großen
und wichtigen Wirtschaftsstandort
Südwestfalen der für Deutschland so
wichtig ist wieder neu beleben können
vielen Dank
Paul ziemiak für die Unionsfraktion er
ist ja seit kurzem auch
CDU-Generalsekretär in
Nordrhein-Westfalen
wir nähern uns so langsam dem Ende
dieser Debatte Stefan gelb heißt
allerdings noch dran verkehrspolitischer
Sprecher der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren politische Amnesie hat
ziemiak ist anscheinend weit verbreitet
in diesem Haus 13.000 Brücken land auf
Land ab 13.000 nicht 4.000 verfallen
lassen und dann sich beklagen hey das
dauert zu lange mit dem Wiederaufbau
sorry aber das geht nicht sie müssen da
schon sagen Horst und Reiter wie ist
denn das passiert wie sind denn diese
Brücken zerbröselt wer hat denn da in 12
Jahren eine Priorität gesetzt und wie
wurde die gesetzt wenn die so gesetzt
wurde das Brücken zerbrös sind dass man
die dann sperren muss dass man dann
daran kommen muss dieser Sanierung zu
machen das passiert doch das fällt doch
nicht vom Himmel und jetzt stellen sich
hier ein Pult und erzählen was vom Pferd
dass das passt nicht zusammenziehen ja
das passt einfach nicht zusammen
ja dieses Land ist zu langsam beim Bau
von Infrastrukturprojekten das ist
vollkommen unbestritten aber was dieser
vorschlagen das hilft auch nicht möchten
Herr Kollege
Herr Kollege sie haben eindrucksvoll
bewiesen das was ich ihnen unterstellt
habe das einzige worüber sie sprechen
ist auf andere zu zeigen und über die
Vergangenheit zu sprechen lassen sie uns
ja lassen Sie uns doch jetzt einfach mal
also meine Bitte wäre und meine Frage
sind Sie bereit in ihrer Rede noch etwas
zu sagen wie wir die Brücke jetzt so
schnell wie möglich aufbauen können und
welche Verbesserungsvorschläge Sie zu
unserem Gesetzentwurf haben
es lohnt immer ein bisschen abzuwarten
dann dann merkt man auch was im Vortrag
dann noch so kommt aber klar erster Satz
dazu wenn man viel
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz im letzten
Legislatur vorlegt und keiner sich mit
diesem Thema adressiert finde ich schön
dass Sie jetzt einen fünften vorlegt
bisher hat keiner ihrer
Gesetzesvorschläge irgendeine Planung
beschleunigt das kann man festhalten und
auch dieser wird es ehrlich gesagt wenn
sie ehrlich sind nicht tun zweiter Punkt
zweiter Punkt zu stellen die
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung infrage da
und zwar mit dem Hintergrund wenn
besonders viel Verkehr generiert werden
kann dann wollen sie das Beschleunigen
nee vielen Dank nicht mehr Verkehr wir
sagen mehr Mobilität und das muss auch
in ihrem Vorschlag mal mitgedacht werden
das passiert nicht und das ist verrückt
dritter Punkt
sie schlagen in ihrem Gesetzentwurf vor
und das ist finde ich bemerkenswert dass
wir das im Paragraph 6 wenn sie
nachlesen wollen dass sie da bei der
Vergabe und Nachprüfung
die richtige Überprüfung massiv
einschränken wollen sie war ganz viel
rauskürzen dem Auftraggeber freier Hand
lassen und ganz ehrlich dass der Weg in
die verantwortschaft und ganz ehrlich
Bürokratie ist kein selbstweg sogar
beieinander ja aber gerade die
unionskollegen haben nicht nur in der
Pandemie sondern auch bei der Maut bei
den Berater Verträgen beim Zentrum
Mobilität gezeigt dass es gerichtlich
Überprüfung braucht dass wir klare
saubere Verfahren brauchen und ihm keine
Vorteile herrenart
[Applaus]
und dann der Fokus des Gesetzes
Straßenbau kein Wort zu Wasserstraßen
Straßenbau kein Wort zu Fahrradwegen zu
Bahninfrastruktur oder zu ÖPNV
Straßenbau noch nicht mal ein Wort zu
Ladeinfrastruktur oder Digitalisierung
nur nur Straßenbau bei einem der
dichtesten straßennätze der Welt und für
ziemiak noch eins sie haben gefragt wie
man das beschleunigen kann ja bauen wir
doch die Brücke in gleicher Art und
Weise auf dann brauchen wir auch keine
Verträglichkeitsprüfung das wissen sie
und trotzdem gibt es die Vorschläge das
Ding breiter zu machen das sieht dann
Zeit ne das sind die Probleme die ihre
Vorschläge im aufwerfen
so und jetzt noch zu Herrn Hirte sie
haben kritisiert sie haben kritisiert
dass wir hier quasi nicht auf die Straße
des fokussieren noch mal da der Satz und
haben dann gesagt LNG Terminals und
Windkraftanlagen das so muss man auch
machen der Gedanke der daran falsch ist
ist das eine wird mit bitter gebraucht
beim anderen haben wir das dichteste
Straßennetz der Welt eines der
wichtigsten Belgien Niederlande ja
natürlich brauchen wir die Brücke aber
hier entwurften bezieht sich ehrlich
gesagt da steht nicht drauf
Beschleunigungsgesetz für die
Lüdenscheid Fragen sondern da steht
drauf bundeslandstraße und Brücken nein
das steht viel mehr drin und deswegen
deswegen müssen sie sich fragen lassen
was brauchen wir denn wirklich in diesem
Land und diese Frage beantworten Sie
nicht sondern sie stellen einfach nur
die Mitte Straßen Straßen Straßen und
Straßen und da frage ich sie noch mal
zurück wo ist denn die
technologieoffenheit von der sie immer
reden wo ist denn der Klimaschutz den
sie da im Munde führen nichts ist davon
da und deswegen taucht der Antrag auch
einfach nichts und deswegen nehmen wir
ihn ab vielen Dank
Stefan gelb heißt der verkehrspolitische
Sprecher der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen oder der bei der vorletzte Redner
in dieser Debatte zu einem Antrag der
Unionsfraktion zu beschleunigten
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren an
Brücken und Fernstraßen letzte Redner
aus der SPD-Fraktion Matthias Stein
ja liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
freue mich außerordentlich dass ich zu
diesem Thema sprechen kann in der
letzten Wahlperiode haben wir gemeinsam
mit der
cdu/csu-fraktion versucht
planungsbeschleunigung zu machen Dinge
schneller zu machen wir haben auch
einiges erreicht und das Thema Planungs-
und baubeschleunigung das ist so etwas
Knüppel für Knüppel zu beseitigen das
ist eine wirklich Kerne Arbeit und das
darf sich nicht allein nur auf
Gesetzesänderung beschränken meine Damen
und Herren
wir stehen vor einem gewaltigen
Transformationsprozess das ist hier
angesprochen worden wir wollen
klimaneutral werden in einer sehr großen
Geschwindigkeit wir wollen unsere
Energieversorgung sichern und wir so
müssen auch dazu beitragen dass wir
Industrienationen das sind wirklich
kernarbeiten und wir haben es
gleichzeitig damit zu tun dass unsere
Infrastruktur in die Jahre gekommen sind
nicht nur in die Jahre gekommen sind
sondern auch unsere Infrastruktur wurde
auch auf Verschleiß gefahren wir haben
viel zu viel Belastungen auf die Brücken
aufgetragen und das holt uns jetzt an
dieser Stelle ein die Lieferketten sind
angespannt wenn man so reinhört und wir
erleben das jetzt bei der
rammeltalbrücke das ist sozusagen hier
zu einem GAU gekommen ist es ist aber
auch bei mir im Wahlkreis zu einem GAU
gekommen im Mittwoch ist ein Kran am
Nord Kanal in die Holtenauer Hochbrücken
hineingefahren die Messung waren leider
fehlerhaft die Ladepapiere waren
vermutlich fehlerhaft und die Brücke es
ist jetzt immer noch für den
motorisierten Verkehr gesperrt das heißt
ich habe auch in meinem eigenen
Wahlkreis jetzt am Leibe erfahren wie
das ist wenn Brücken ausfallen an
Bundesstraßen und ich glaube wir müssen
wesentlich sorgsamer auch mit unserer
Infrastruktur umgehen und ich glaube ein
Bereich gehört dazu der hier an dieser
Stelle ganz wichtig ist wir müssen all
diejenigen den Rücken stärken die für
Infrastruktur arbeiten die den Betrieb
der Infrastruktur gewährleisten das sind
die Planerinnen und Planer das sind die
unsere Ingenieurinnen und Ingenieure
das sind aber auch unsere
Handwerkerinnen und Handwerker die jetzt
wirklich in mühsamer Arbeit bei jedem
Unglück dass wir haben da versuchen den
Laden zum Laufen zu halten und ich finde
das müsste mal ein großes Dankeschön vom
gesamten Haus hier mal kommen
und dazu nein das ist nicht Ironie
sondern ich habe selber in diesen
Baustellen auch gearbeitet und ich weiß
wenn Leute in Nachtschicht arbeiten und
wir sozusagen uns hier hinstellen und
einfach so zu tun als würden wir mit
einer blanken Gesetzesänderung das
herbeiheben wir brauchen Personal wir
brauchen ein Fitnessprogramm wir
brauchen mehr Wissenschaft in dem
Bereich Bauindustrie das wissen wir
alles und dazu müssen wir kämpfen und
wir
Sozialdemokratinnen und Sozialdemokraten
sind bereit die Zahlen diesen Menschen
wirklich Respekt und wir werden wirklich
harte 10 Jahre haben in dieser für diese
Arbeit damit wir unsere Infrastruktur
tatsächlich auch auf ein wirklich guten
Stand bringen und da hilft es auch nicht
so zu tun als sei der hauptufer Ursache
hat warum ist nicht vorangeht die
schlimmen Umweltverbände wissen Sie ich
habe damit Planungs wollen viel zu tun
hat das sind manchmal nicht
Umweltverbände sondern das sind
tatsächlich auch Anwohner die Angst vor
Lärm und Erschütterung haben und wenn
wir dann einfach sagen wir stellen uns
hin und ignorieren diese Sachen dann
werden wir nicht schneller bauen dann
werden wir langsamer bauen
und deshalb ist diese
fortschrittskoalition diese
Ampelkoalition bereit dass wir in
infrastrukturkonsens machen um dort an
dieser Stelle schneller zu bauen wir
packen an mit den Menschen und ich
glaube das werden wir Sie auch bei der
planungsbeschleunigung sehen wir werden
für mehr Personalsorgen wir werden für
mehr Fachlichkeit und wir werden diesen
Menschen den Rücken stärken ich wünsche
allen ein schönes Wochenende vielen Dank
Matthias Stein aus der SPD-Fraktion mit
einem leidenschaftlichen Plädoyer für
beschleunigte Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren das geht ja ein
Teil durchaus auch im Land wie wir bei
lng-terminals in Norddeutschland gesehen
haben da wurde die Zeit rapide verkürzt
im Moment mit dem Ergebnis dass sich die
Kosten auch verdoppelt haben da muss man
mal gucken ob da die verkürzten
Planungs- und genehmigungszeiten
möglicherweise ein Teil zu beigetragen
haben der Antrag der Unionsfraktion wird
dem Verkehrsausschuss weiter diskutiert
werden dann werden wir vielleicht
irgendwann mal wieder sehen